sont consacrés à jean teulé jean tenait
pour son nouveau roman
charly 9 paru chez julliard jean teulé
bonsoir bonsoir bon alors à peine
digérée de mme angèle aussi le jeu voici
un charlie 9 bien saignant au menu quand
j'ai dit si bien saignant c'est que le
sang c'est quand même un élément
déterminant puisque ça commence par la
saint-barthélemy tout ça est marqué par
la saint barthélémy c'est qu'il charline
charles neuf c'était
le roi de france 61e rois de france
et qui à 22 ans a ordonné un truc
absolument immonde le massacre de tous
les protestants massacre surprise le
jour de la saint barthélémy et il ne
voulait absolument pas ordonner se
classer sa mère catherine de médicis qui
arrivait la veille le samedi soir vers
21h et qui lui a dit voilà qu'il
faudrait buts et où les protestants
voilà alors ça quand même il ya il est
bien frappé ce charlie n'a pas ce que
alors il ya son adolescence où déjà il
annonçait quelques signes c'est ce
garçon avait des comportements un peu
étrange pas absolument toute façon
c'était les valois qui arrivé en bout de
course il risque donc aucune race et
tous et commencer tous à devenir un peu
dégénéré un peu taré et 800 malin et
voilà et puis mais lui c'était un petit
roi faibles et tout ce qu'ils ne
voulaient pas et 3 qui passaient
d'ailleurs son temps à dire je ne
voulais pas être roi je n'étais pas
décidé à régner c'est mon père et mon
frère qui sont mort trop tôt et c'est un
gamin qui se retrouve valence et dans la
deuxième moitié du xvième siècle les
guyer de religion qui comprend plus rien
à rien qui est complètement paumé
et ce qui est formidable dans ce début
c'est qu'on part pour un meurtre on part
pour un assassinat
ouais jusqu'à dessus allez tous voila
voila ça commence comme ça ils ont
commencé en disant qu'il fallait deux
buts et l'amiral de coligny qu'après il
passe à 6,10 100000 10000 et 20000 30
mills a dit absolument n'importe quoi et
un moment charles neuf qui refusaient
qui refusaient toulouse de ceux de cette
réunion
tout d'un coup cra qui dit vous voulez
de contenu des protestants est battu et
les tous mais je veux parce que je veux
jamais voir un visage jamais entendu une
voix qui me reproche ce que je leur
donnais et finalement la personne qui va
le plus reprocher la saint barthélemy à
charles 9 s'est lui même
ils vont devenir d'un gamin alors ce
freluquet et quand même ardent sur la
chose
c'est moi qu'on puisse dire il ya une
scène d'embouteillage en plein paris où
il est bon il est avec sa maîtresse dont
il aura un fils totti 3 et qu il n
oubliera quant à esker reste et il est
coincé dans les embouteillages et il
fait sa petite affaire où ses petites
affaires sa grosse affaire parce que
c'est parce que il dit c'est donc on
parle là de marie touché que ça ne fasse
une protestante qui l'ordonné qu'elle
soit gueule gracié et pas tuer à la
saint barthélémy et il disait je ne
quitte jamais marie toucher sans en
avoir joui trois fois belle santé
voilà
voilà alors c'est vrai qu'on commence à
saint barth avait vu il dit touché par
ambroise paré touchez pas à ma maîtresse
et toucher pas mal non exactement oui
les protège parce que sont entourés de
protestants et colony week-end important
mais il l'appelait mon père et même son
secrétaire particulier était protestant
et ses artistes préférés étaient
protestants
ce qui fait que cole quand quelques
jours après saint barthélemy l'a dit
mais pourquoi je vois plus mes artistes
ça
les gens qui bossent qui étaient autour
de lui on dit bassir il ya quand même un
problème ils étaient protestants
donc ils ont forcément tous s'étaient
butés parce que le paradoxe avec charles
loos et qui il aimait bien les
protestants il avait rien contre eux et
c'est lui qui les a fait massacrer leur
masse alors il des faits il est fait
massacrer parce que là c'est pourquoi on
est pendant les guerres de religion
comme vous l'avez dit il y en a eu vite
on va entrer dans la 4e y en a déjà eu 3
3 avant et il ya quand même je crois un
petit clin d'oeil à l'époque puisque
vers la fin au moment des funérailles
hier à la barre allah akbar oui mais
voilà et il ya un mec qui diop dans le
cortège funéraire gueule allah akbar et
je mets en plus qu'est ce qu'il fout là
lui et ça veut dire que voilà toutes les
religions quel bordel ses revenus voilà
et c'est le message qu'il y a dans ce
livre au delà du message un haut niveau
avec de la saveur fait que ça ça vit
bien
puis ça bouge que l'on rigole part
est-ce que je peux sur le dit souvent
que les jusque-là lévis seront là savard
tmi je les ai trouvés sinistre parce qu'
il était temps qu'ils en arrivent à
marans
bah voilà
[Musique]
l'énergie comme temps libre bon au moins
saignant va bien que notre petit bout
alors ce petit beau c'est l'occasion
pour notre invité de revenir sur un
sujet qui aquila ou agacer ou qui
voudraient comme monte en ce moment
c'est un manque pas mais c'est sans
doute parce que je suis dans charlie nov
il ya un pasteur évangéliste un beau
tard et là il s'appelle terry jones
chamakh à un américain qui fait des
autodafé du coran et je veux dit ben
voilà on y est on y retourne et ça me
donne raison d'avoir fait daverat fait
saliver et j'y vais ça mais ça va jamais
finir ces conneries de religion est
quand même invraisemblable et que c'est
con d'aller brûler le coran de tout
comme c'est très con ce que peuvent
faire aussi les islamistes quant au
caire y [ __ ] le feu à des
l'église chrétienne copte et tout mais
timide big quand la planète va devenir
adulte ait pu avoir besoin de ce père
noël à la conte pour adultes qu'on
appelle les religions gens conclut jean
teulé est athée ah ouais ouais ouais bah
oui militants presque athée mais oui oui
oui mais en même temps moi ça me dérange
pas que les gens croient moi dans ma
famille il ya des gens qui croient même
à plusieurs des religions différentes et
tout le monde mais il ya eu de 1789 dont
il ya eu la révolution française truc
génial
la laïcité n'est pas un mélange pas la
religion et l'état et en même temps
chacun 3 ce qu'il veut a parqué devant
moi qui fais pas chier les autres
formidable est ce que quand vous pensez
aux religions vous avez quelques
espérances quand même que c'est les
leçons comme celle que que vous donnez
soient écoutés ou c'est pas du tout le
chemin concours à ça je trouve c'est pas
du tout du tout le chemin content mais
et mais je me dis que des gens comme
sarkozy guéant tous à l'eau au second de
terry jones et tous ces gens là ce il
devrait lire mon livre pour se rendre
compte où ça mène les guerres de
religion à quel niveau de folie aurait
contenu on a tué tellement de gens à la
saint barthélemy à paris que les jours
qui ont suivi on pouvait traverser la
piscine à pied en passant d'un corps sur
l'autre on sait comme est-ce que des
fois jean teulé se dit ça pourrait
arriver aujourd'hui ou pas mais moi je
vois ça arrivait à fond mais bien sûr ah
oui je vois c'est arrivé
vraiment vraiment on sent que toutes les
religions frotte ce c'est presque si
c'est ici que je sais c'est comme dédé
des déplacements deux continents qui
fois que là on se sent que ça frotte et
il est placé en dessous des voix
valables et et voilà c'est tout bon
alors ce coup de sifflet pour annoncer
l'arrivée là d'un article en général pas
très aimable sur notre invité ses dents
service littéraire le mensuel de
l'actualité romanesque c'est juillet
août 2009
c'est monsieur pierre cornut gentille un
livre alors miamiam c'est sûr mangez le
si vous voulez un livre racoleur et
anthropophage avec des phases aussi
plate callen budget l'histoire est
terrifiant c'est celle du supplice
infligé un jeune homme sympathique et
apprécié de tous par une foule devenue
folle
le 16 août 1870 le brave alain de
monnaie a été conspué frapper sa victime
torturé brûlé vif et même mangé par
plusieurs centaines de villageois
hystérique
y aurait-il manière un roman historique
jean teulé fort du succès mérité de son
montespan la crue mais s'est trompé le
roman historique suppose d'enjoliver de
combler des lacunes d'inventer des
dialogues des épisodes de données
l'épaisseur de la vie aux archi faux
témoignage
exhumé par les historiens mais quand les
faits réels dépasse l'imagination
il faut lui livré brut sans fioritures
sans effets de style au lieu de spa jean
teulé croyant mettre la patte du
romancier enchaîne les phrases aussi
plate qu'elle en piqué qui affadissent
le récit de points citation à c'est du
propre et d'hugo que lui torse nu
contrefaits en carnage il palpite entier
en sa forme total sur ce rêve aller
j'allais le dire
ironisant je me dis c'est moi qui écris
ça c'est pas mal et faisait la même
bref le résultat est examen au contraire
à celui recherché
d'accord sur la notion de style parquet
ce qui l'a provoquée comme réaction chez
les ch et d'électeur pour vous tournez
justement vous avez parlé l'été dernier
des gens qui étaient qui était con pas
pu le finir ce livre parce que vraiment
ils étaient très dures manger le et et
puis il ya des gens qui me reprocher de
l'avoir en compte et raconter aux dix
ans on raconte pas ce type d'histoire
c'est pour ab pourquoi on raconte est
tabou ben voilà ouais et puis c'était la
honte de la france ce sont des bons
français normaux quand on fait ça et
j'ai rencontré mode des descendants dans
des séances de dédicaces des gens qui
ont participé à ce massacre qui étaient
des arrière-petits-enfants parce que ça
s'est passé il ya pas si longtemps que
ça et qui disait que dans la famille
encore aujourd'hui c'était no comments à
un mot c'est c'est la honte et jean-tony
comment réagit-il en général face aux
critiques vraiment bien parce que en
plus j'en ai très rarement des mauves
être vraiment très rarement et jeu là
pour le moment je n'ai pas à souffrir de
ça ça me turlupine pas ils font ce
qu'ils veulent et puis nous sommes pas
au zéro problème j'ai même pas nous ne
nous ont même pas envie de me moquer
d'eux rien font skieuses
[Musique]
donc cette caméra dans la main de notre
invité c'est pour dire on va nous
raconter une anecdote nous ce qui lui
revient par la tête aujourd'hui ce dont
il a envie de parler selon l'humeur j'en
envie de me raconter qu'elle est avec
dot quand on lui met la petite caméra
drama desk j'ai souvenir d'enfance de
tourner à souvenirs d'enfant si j'en ai
un
ma grand mère était très catholique et
et le dimanche matin là elle est la
première messe et à ma soeur est à moi
nous poser à tous les deux une pas si de
menthe sur la table de nuit qui
apprenait dans une armoire où il y avait
plein d'humilité
tous les matins tous les dimanches
matins nous ont bouffées à pacy de
menthe en attendant notre grand-mère qui
revenaient de la messe et city le goût
du bonheur
tellement que plus tard
quand je suis devenu adulte souvent
quand je suis passé devant une boutique
où on vendait pas si durement dû rouler
en acheter une
et à chaque fois je goûtais et j'étais
déçu quand je faisais l'assiette
anglaise un jour je vais faire un
reportage chez une vieille mamie ont fui
en fait tout le reportage et lundi voulu
une passivement suivant ma voiture et
mon dos nu j'ai un goût tu l'as pas si
demande de ma grand mère
mais vous vous achetez ça et toussus
raconte ça fait 20 ans que j'essaye
toews a indiqué ce qu'ils ont mais pas
si je mentais l'enfant utmb dans la
bouche mais elle est moisi en fait ma
grand-mère mettre toute mon enfance et
bouffer des pastilles de menthe moisi et
elle sans ressort le méchant si elle ne
savait pas du tout et pour moi ça va
c'était c'est sale goût du bonheur du
bonheur un petit goût de moisi et ben
voilà c'est le bonheur c'est une phase
i/ii manque moisi pour moi la série
jolie feinte alors on parle du en parle
du bonheur
voilà c'est on parlait de religion
cranna qu'en son temps
c'est au musée du luxembourg il ya une
exposition ivoire d un café à adam et
eve qui sont fameux et est célèbre
voilà il faut aller voir cette
exposition tout le monde connaît cette
représentation d'adam et eve de crack
voilà c'est notre petit bercy
cad aulas sur ol lyon selon mme avait
vachement plus piégeuse j'adore j'adore
la peinture je suis très content voilà
on parle avec vous jean teulé de charly
9 votre dernier roman chez julliard est
déjà un très gros succès mérité je
remercie
[Musique]